last week after jesse smallett was
sentenced to prison for perpetrating a
ludicrous race hoax in chicago the
actress brother made one last
impassioned and implausible plea
for his brother's innocence
there is absolutely no evidence linking
jesse to staging his own hate crime
besides the testimony of two brothers
claimed jokey smollette
now of course
there was lots of evidence there was the
testimony of the attackers who were not
white racist gay bashers but in fact
nigerian homosexuals there were records
of smilet having paid the brothers there
were records of the nigerian brothers
purchasing the tools for the hoax there
was security camera footage and there
was of course the sheer implausibility
of white trump supporters even
recognizing the little-known actor while
prowling the streets of chicago claiming
it was magga country
and attempting to lynch smolette while
he somehow held on to his subway
sandwich
lots
and lots and lots of evidence and yet
jesse is having the last laugh
now that he has been released from
prison after just a few days
and he convinced an appeals court judge
to free him by you guessed it
playing the race card smilet's lawyer
argued quote there is no room in our
court system for
politics
regardless of what you think about this
case the real question is should black
men be walked into jail for a class 4
felony
yes
the answer to that question of course is
yes men of all races should be walked
into jail for felonies but that wasn't
the question at all
the question was should black men be
held to lower standards by society if
they play the race card
should we let psychos and criminals off
the hook
if they can make even the most dubious
claims to be victims
in a sane society in traditional society
in mega country everyone is equal before
the law
but in our unjust society
jesse smilet goes free and so does his
attacker so smilet
perpetrates a hoax he gets caught
completely dead to rights he is
sentenced he makes a big crazy scene in
his sentencing and tries to make it all
about race and says he's a black
political dissident
you know who's being persecuted by the
government
and then his lawyer goes in and plays
the race card even more and says black
men shouldn't be arrested for felonies
that's his argument white men that's
fine asian men yeah throw them in the
can but black men black men are so super
duper special they need to be held to a
much lower standard and what happens the
judge agrees with him and the judge lets
him off the hook race
is this magical little thing that you
can play that will get you out of
anything
[Music]